in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Eric
and Julie are with us hey guys how are
you great how are you
welcome welcome where are you from we're
from Exeter New Hampshire which is just
outside of Portsmouth Oh God very cool
well welcome to Nashville and here to do
your debt-free scream yes sir
excellent how much have you paid off
just over eighty four thousand dollars
Wow and how long did that take 31 months
good and your range of income during
that time from 100 to 110 excellent what
do you guys do for a living I'm a
guidance counselor mm-hmm and I'm a
police officer
Oh neat very cool good for you guys so
what kind of debt was the 84,000
school loans school says Julie which
means they were hers so how long have
you two been married
coming up on 11 years okay excellent so
two and a half years ago something
happened that made you get real serious
about getting out of debt what was it I
work nights and you play on a radio
station so I discovered you on the radio
one night and listening to these
inspiring stories I realized that we had
spent at the time about ten years
spinning our wheels and treading water
and really making no progress and I did
the math and I realized that we had
another 15 years of that ahead if we
didn't change what we were doing in
their lives yeah
and that was just that was too much to
bear so I had a long conversation with
my wife it was long what does that sound
like Julie what is he talking about
I mean he was sort of planting the seed
for a while that we needed to do
something different and we just we just
realized that we wanted to make sure
that in our retirement and we could
provide for our children that we weren't
you know in debt and paying off all
these loans and I had another about what
twelve and a half years left in my
graduate loans do you know fifteen and a
half years left so we we just decided to
try something different and I said that
I was on board that there were a few
things that were still really important
to me if I was going to take this
journey with him and you know in our we
have a really strong marriage and a lot
really great communication
and we sat down and we really talked it
out and oh cool I was on board pretty
quick okay all right so planted some
seeds and then once you kind of got the
vision then you said okay I'll do it
under these here's how I'm gonna do it
and we line it out and went after it so
what do you say the key to paying off
eighty-four thousand dollars worth of
debt in 31 months is Julie well I think
that there definitely was that
conversation that was important things
that are important to me like running
and races and running shoes and things
like that
was that where does that fit in my life
still because if I were to give up
something that's such a big passion of
mine I was worried that I wouldn't be
able to have the endurance to keep this
journey so so it really was just that
there was a lot of things we pulled back
on there were a lot of cash envelopes
and after a while it really was just we
saw the progress we started checking off
you know the debt and seeing those red
like flashes through each of the the
debt that we had you know put down on
paper and visualize seeing that on the
fridge and it just started that snowball
it really it got exciting yeah you get
the more you get into it it's like it's
working I can do this yeah you know it's
like the first time you do a race you
you know you get to about mile nine and
a half and you're going I don't know if
I want to do this and then all the
sudden you go I get to finish it I can
do this I got this and you you know you
get you get over the hump and you can go
then you know so Eric what do you say
the key to getting out of debt is
communication if if you don't have that
plan and you don't have that support
that mutual support with each other it's
not gonna work mm-hmm you know that
trust and that that strong communication
of understanding what works for her what
doesn't the same thing for me it was the
only way that we were gonna get traction
worked I mean this is pretty dramatic
because you were doing almost $3,000 a
month yes we didn't know where it was
going I until like we started seeing how
much we were saving and able to just
crushing that debt we know why I was
like you know go to Target and I come
home as we have two children and it'd be
like oh I bought this I bought that and
you know now it's just being more
intentional yeah pocket is a black hole
vortex man sucks money out of the
universe
Walmart is - they're both the same way
oh and Sam's is like nine gallons of
peanut butter so there you go
you know oh you guys that's fun very
cool so uh what was the hardest thing I
think for me it was I guess just
changing the lifestyle just you know and
saying no what did you say no - or
change you know even just like going out
to eat a lot a lot of the I want it now
that delayed gratification feeling like
I deserved it because I worked hard
seeing something and seeing my friends
you know move on with their lives and
take vacations and being so happy for
them but realizing you know that's not
our journey right now we'll have that
turn it's just we're delaying it until
we can pay for it so I think for me it
was just I needed a pep talk every few
months right I come home and do like a
pep talk right now you know so great
about grounding me and just saying you
were gonna get there we're going to get
there this is our plan and we're gonna
stick to it live like no one else in
later we can live and give like no one
else there we go very cool that's the
pep talk I love it
well you guys are awesome it's an honor
to meet you congratulations you're
heroes
you took control of your life you know
what you're what's great about this
world all right it's Eric and Julie now
we're gonna give you a copy of a Chris
Hogan's retire inspired book signed by
him that's the next step is in next
chapter in your story is you got this
one beat now let's let's go get the
wealth and as a result let's get the get
the carrot that we were chasing here and
and certainly be able to give
outrageously as a result so very cool
all right Eric and Julie Portsmouth New
Hampshire
$84,000 paid off 31 months making a
hundred to a hundred and ten you did it
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
I love it I love it well done you guys
very very well done and that's fabulous
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or five hundred
thousand dollar income